[Music]
in Supercop news
we are submitted by Slick Rick the ruler
an undercover policeman made 299 gang
arrests in the 11 months he spent on the
case too much is that a lot do can hate
beat up a whole room of guys all on him
is ever happen is that one rest day oh
did he do that thing where he beat up
everyone in the room and like people are
throwing punches over silver and he
knows that they're there and [ __ ] like
action movie yeah like did he make that
bust in like a day it was a day it was a
day by Monday wait 500 officers you got
him on Rico I like saying [ __ ] yeah did
he take down the whole organization cuz
that's like a RICO thing Oh Rico is the
whole organization it's a conspiracy you
could get them from the top to the
bottom there's nothing cooler than
talking cop lingo and saying like we got
him on Rico nothing is cooler than that
[ __ ] dude it's like you got a new lip
before you saying it yeah it's really
cool but it was just unfortunate that
you said it in a room full of people
that didn't know what the [ __ ] that
meant besides Joe I see so kind of fell
in still it sounds sick though I thought
he just messed up his sentence in some
words that don't make sense
I'll try to joke at your guys's level
yeah tone it down a little bit okay oh
that was it you don't have to tone it
down for me I understand
I'm not stupid okay yeah so there's one
undercover detective I you see yeah are
you see see yeah yeah yeah
you see I went that one right over a lot
of heads in here hey cor ten ten four
heed me what it puts talking about him
is homicide robbery homicide one I think
armed robbery I remember what you're
saying freeways 420 is possession of
marijuana it better be and 51 50s like
you're criminally knots or whatever
remember that was super cool signed out
in like middle school I'm too skeptical
to be a cop well first of all this takes
place in Hong Kong and really because
I'm too skeptical be looking at things
from all angles I just can't have
somebody who come down on my ass you
know I'm saying I gotta be I'd be that
kind of cop yeah you do how's the one
that comes down on your ass you come
down on - yeah how so I'm like hey clean
the dishes alright hey yeah that's I'm
saying I can't do that I can't have a
job you know like because my chief would
be all for my [ __ ] ass you know
you'll be the renegade cop we're like
the chief is like give me the badge for
the last time and I'm like you know what
you can take it okay and I'm still gonna
work the funds for the last time you did
you destroyed the city that's it but
then at the end I get the key to the
city
yeah yeah because you find out the
corruption in the police force in are
you talking yeah no I'm just really
afraid of guns okay now it's that for
both of you guys to stick your fingers
outside of each others butts and then we
can hear that welcome I was advised that
part cuz you didn't have your finger in
there I was invited to that okay so yeah
these these criminals that were arrested
they were all under a triad
investigation so they're all part of the
triad mm-hmm they're like ants out there
in China are they there's a lot of them
300 what 299 is one organization this is
in China Hong Kong oh yeah so um so this
one officer he went undercover right
after getting out of the Academy he had
to assume a different identity it become
like completely removed from his family
and friends so from one Chinese guys
were no Chinese guy pretty much yet but
they're like a hoodlum Chinese oh well
he could be so he can gain the trust of
all the
members difference yeah and then so he
ended up losing 30 pounds in this 11
month investigation I got to go
undercover
he's just so stressed out were they all
a part of a Pilates class or something
or that could be well no there are you
from yoga like I gotta go undercover
licensed driver how do I join this game
because a lot of these like leaders they
would meet at asana and one of the
saunas was taken down oh they like that
spa call this is a [ __ ] movie man
yeah and they would also try to see if
he was a snitch by giving him movie
references or like telling him like
things that happened to cops and movies
to see if you would flinch or say like
you was a snitch or something what
that's the worst I mean they're still
running off the 1980s mafia system that
was you've gotta get him to do a bunch
of drugs and make him do something you
gotta give him to shoot a kid or
something
yeah easy that would have been this kid
stole from us so you know take care of
it yeah yeah and if he's down to do it
okay yeah
and if he's not then he's nothing he's
not a cop that's how I check for cuff
yeah if I was in that right yeah not as
for [ __ ] not talked about movie no
not no yeah how did super cop to end did
you see her yeah but this whole
operation it was codenamed super tail
129 that's the name of the movie that
sounds like a Chinese action movie yeah
it's great and they arrested 129 men and
170 women aged from 14 to 70 yeah
they're there even people that were
involved in the city like the district
counselor was among them and like Oh
their game like there were games like
city workers and like government
employees yeah they're also among
regular people mm-hmm and so they were
able to get the officers they seized ten
account books belonging to the whooshing
a triad and weapons 60,000 Hong Kong
dollars and cash small amounts of
illegal drugs and they arrested all
those people as well and then they also
crack down on six unlicensed pubs the
sauna or gambling den den and more than
ten brothels I got nobody owns a [ __ ]
math studio it's like you know it's like
math stars it's like come on in you know
teaching mathematics you know it's gotta
be a brothel a casino a [ __ ] sambar a
nightclub a doughnut falafel shut store
you know it's like they got three
brothels in the Kumaon training center
it's like of course we're gonna check
those places first dude right well they
just want a place that they get perks at
to like they don't get math tutoring
perks that's true what about like a car
wash
yeah they could do car washes probably
it's like the Armenian mafia like a
taffy store it's like you know it's like
you know womb being dentistry it's like
nobody's gonna care we can check the
doctor's office sure nobody cares but
you get [ __ ] there see but it's
always like mechanic shop or you know
all this yeah well maybe those are
mainly like cash business cash business
and they double dip they probably like
steal cars and it's like a chop shop but
at the same time if you need an oil
change you can go there too you could be
surprised how much cash and getting sold
I was in the Mafia there's something I
want like some perks Oh what would you
pick probably like a kitty farm you know
nobody's bunch of kittens running around
being real cute how do you want
adoptions
very expensive adoption neutering good
breeding but I don't recommend that
that's really cruel right so it's like a
vet it's like a vet or maybe a cat
sanctuary yeah cat seems a nonprofit
organization I just think that a lot of
these organizations have evolved in like
in the States and I think in a couple
years we're gonna find out like all
these hipster places like in Silver Lake
have been told fronts like all the
juicer ease the pressed freakin coffee
[ __ ] like all that slow drip yeah give
me a break you know all that [ __ ] I
would love to find out that all that way
you know what I would bet that like the
vintage shops are maybe French because
like who spends that much money on an
old frying pan all the hipsters rich
people dude in how many freaking
furniture stores are in LA which one was
that way no one all the corner
yeah the corner corner one which one
camera yep yeah dude knowing there's so
many of them unlike how there's like
more furniture shops than people and in
this the markups really high so they
could get it really cheap so that's
probably the price for anything yeah but
then in the in the couch they probably
ship heroin hell another neither always
is shown in there with the lights off
yeah bad with the carwash where they
just have to like write it in that they
had X amount of cars that came in but
that's how they launder money exactly
that's how I learned about money
laundering we were watching the ozark oh
I haven't heard it's so good jason
bateman you just don't like Game of
Thrones so I can't take care it's not
that we don't like it I just got
confused I would watch it
I don't like accents I said you can't do
that you can't fold yeah I don't know
yeah I had that same problem of narcos
because I tried to do other [ __ ] but
that show is subtitle so you can't even
look like down real quick to eat like
spaghetti yeah like you have to like be
looking at the whole damn time yeah
which reminds me I gotta finish my
normal season like two seasons all right
I stopped that mint - yeah okay oh it's
really good thank you very much
hey guys I hope you enjoyed that episode
of just kidding news and if there's a
story that you guys want us to talk
about go ahead down into our description
box below and there's a link there where
you can submit articles for the next
video click right up here
[Music]